après on a fait rentrer et à julie
raynaud la productrice passe
[Applaudissements]
julie raynaud qu'est ce qui vous le dis
si vous nous rejoignez julie raynaud ont
envoyé un sms à leur triomphe faisait
très chaud sur matt pokora
elle m'a dit elle m'a dit voilà moi je
qu'est ce qu'elles lui feraient bien des
colis ça faisait un mois que je ne sais
pas quel jeu c'est parce qu'ils
confondent lg je croise un autre
pourquoi c'est la productrice de thé pmp
merci et je voudrais je vais revenir
plus souvent et je vous dis ça c'est
pour le poser sur sa lune mater mon
style non match aussi que vous êtes
attaqués voilà c'est quand même une très
belle fille c'est une belle femme oui
quand même
vous êtes magnifique alors il ya un bon
soir comment savez-vous savoie xavier a
bien versé 11 et déjà vu d'ailleurs vous
êtes voyons we have ses voyants
astrologues c'est quoi alors voyons un
astrologue d'accord très bien alors matt
tong ou titre s'appelle les planètes
est ce que tu crois en l'astrologie ou
pas du tout oui ouais ouais un peu ta
dire consulter une voyante
non parce que j'ai peur de savoir l'as
vence d'apport de sabre à la main alors
maths alors là j'ai l'impression que je
fais ça si tu vivras votre thème juste
avant de venir
donc vous voulez bien alors vous allez
il va des banques vous avez déjà fait un
truc avec des cartes exactement ce qu'il
va faire il doit choisir une carte alors
de carrière pour voir un peu justement
match
si vous permettez nous donc son corps à
bonjour bonjour
donc je vous montrais ce jeu de cartes
et bien c'est très sympa que julie
raynaud sur cette séquence avec votre
main vous allez juste coupé le jeu est
juste juste avant alors est-ce que vous
parce que nous on est quelqu'un utiliser
dans la choucroute parents vous vous
lisez dans quoi alors écoutez j'ai
d'autres supports effectivement comme le
chocolat
[Applaudissements]